you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
his seventh comedy special live at the
State Theater in Minneapolis is Amazon
Prime's first original comedy special
and it's been streaming exclusively on
Amazon Prime since the middle of this
month and his first leading role in a
thriller American dreamer will premiere
nationally on September the 20th good to
see you Jim Gaffigan thank you for
having me tonight should I say that it's
Jim Gaffigan as you've never seen him
before as you've never seen him before
it's like it's only taken me 30 years to
get an acting role but I'm thrilled so
let's get into that real quick here yeah
why'd you if you wanted to do something
where you're playing a I guess a
psychotic individual or just out on his
luck that things begin to really spiral
out of control
it's or everyman you know it's like I
think every man is kind of inches away
from psychotic and ya know it was an
amazing script and it's uh it was an ND
so you don't know what you're gonna get
when you show up but it's an amazing
director and it was a great crew we you
know did a lot of stuff with Old
Dominion we were in Norfolk so it was it
was this perfect storm of a lot of an
amazing cast so it worked out it's like
it's one of those things where I do
indie films because I I love acting yes
I love proving that I can act but this
one's good
this one's good this is this is one of
those where people you know you might
watch it on a plane but you're gonna be
surprised well war it's one of where
people you think people who just look at
you a little differently
I hope so just a little bit like is is
that is Jim playing any part of himself
in this film I think as an actor you
have to find yourself in the character
you have to justify every decision right
and after a while you kind of I wouldn't
say you get lost but like people would
be like oh I can't believe your
character did that and you're kind of
thinking well that's the only thing he
could do right and it's a horrible thing
that he's done yes it is
I don't how deep do you want to get into
this stuff
he actually did oh he does some heavy
stuff I mean he's essentially a
rideshare driver and as we know some
people do it as kind of a side job or
maybe they're going through school and
then there's people that like that's the
last job they can get so this is his
last job he can get and he eventually
starts driving around this drug dealer
and he continues to make more and more
bad decisions it could
it covers one night but it also kind of
looks at you know entitlement what he
can get away with because he's a white
guy versus if he was someone in a
different position right and and so it's
a rideshare guy who picks up a dealer
starts young driving the dealer around
and then decides to use the dealer's
child:yeah to actually make some money
himself he makes let's go a little
sideways from there um I have to say
I've seen you in car commercials this is
the worst car commercial this is a
different car commercial it's even
different from your Honda Odyssey of
where you are talking about loving it
it's not an ad you know by the way a lot
of people think oh rich is paid to do
those on the ad Odyssey ad no that's I
do you just you're like hey I know that
we're focusing on sports and
entertainment on the show but I'd like
to talk about this car
I've seen your your minivan commercials
yes and I think you are a man who does
love minivans I don't even own a car I
don't I live in New York City so you
don't you just course when you live on
my kids I can't even get all my children
in a cab so we have to do the uber XL
which is like $900 a block so so you
just said this is your first real acting
role clearly you're a minivan commercial
then isn't a true acting role that's
well I played myself in that and this is
not my first acting role well you know
you just I know that yeah well I uh I
also kind of make light of the fact that
I you know loved acting but you know you
have no control over how you get acting
work and I think as comedians were kind
of spoiled because I can come up with
and go on you know Gotham comedy club
tonight and ride that idea
whereas acting you just have to beg for
work yeah I mean what do you mean by
that actually no I mean that thing
auditioning it's kind of like stripping
except for you don't get a dollar that's
what it's like and there's no touching
right there's no touch no touch there's
no touching unless you're in the room
all right
you know Jim Gaffigan here on the Rich
Eisen show so you are from the great
state of India I am what what town
what's your hometown
I'm from Chesterton I lived in Munster
okay so you know Indianapolis sports
fans are being painted as what's the
word for it inappropriate yes for booing
Andrew Luck which is the field it's
really uh kind of upsetting because
going through I took great pride in when
the Peyton Manning stuff went down that
how the Irsay's and Peyton dealt with
kind of that breakup yes that it was
done very civilly and with dignity I
know that like Colts fans were
blindsided and and I understand the
emotional reaction but obviously it is
up to him you know I mean and Andrew
Luck smarter than any of us right so I
don't question his judgment ability yeah
I mean so uh but it is strange because
you know we're not talking and I live in
the Northeast but we're not talking
about fans in the Northeast where they
boo someone just to boo someone like in
in Indiana you know they're they're
relatively polite like I've talked to
Colts fans are like going to
Philadelphia for a game it's like such a
crisis you know or like even when I went
to the Super Bowl and there were like
when the Colts played the Saints and you
would think people sold their homes in
Louisiana to go to the Super Bowl
because you didn't get a sense that like
these this it was this like they're like
you know what there is no tomorrow right
so but Colts fans are normally very
polite so I was kind of surprised with
the booing yeah I mean it was
it took a lot of people by surprise but
so down as you point out Lux retirement
ya know and and and there's just been so
many different opinions yeah on
something that could be as simple as
like the guy spending the last three
weeks just trying to rehab trying to
keep it out of the news because he
doesn't want to make it about an
integrand then just waking up one day
sigh just can't do it
oh I mean it's it could be just as
simple as that
eventually anyone who plays football
quits dear I mean hmm and so we just I
mean some of it it's just of course with
Andrew Luck it's the timing right it's
not like it was after that big injury it
was kind of like he sprained his ankle
and and it just got progressively worse
in the more bizarre fashion that but got
more and more serious even though he
didn't do anything but I went you know
cuz I'm gonna make this about me
when I quit football in college it takes
a lot of bravery because you're letting
down your teammates and but you also
it's not like he just thought of it that
morning you know I mean it's not like
Andrew Luck woke up and you know was
like you know what I want to be I want
to be on Dancing with the Stars instead
it was it was obviously something that
he contemplated for a long time and as
the Andrew Luck publicist I would also
say that it's just weird it's weird and
by the way you know I don't know if you
talked about this yesterday mmm
sometimes like when Sanders quit early
yes the Lions had a really good year
yeah I mean and Calvin Johnson quit
early and the Lions had a good year
I guess they lead the league in early
retirement and shot early retirement
players I think the Colts could still
win this I think they do still win this
division I still think that they're good
enough all over the place
absorb even this shocking state of
affairs I really do believe it's gonna
be the topic that people reference all
year long because we know there's gonna
be some catastrophic injury hmm and
that's gonna bring it back up like well
you know you know someone's going
a Theismann kind of injury and people
are gonna be like well maybe Andrew Luck
was right can I look fatter in this
visual I think I can by the way I think
you looked slimming
I don't now thank you well I do also
just showed a photograph of you from
your playing days yes well that was
actually a photo of look at that neck
roll that's Greg Olson but no that's Jim
Gaffigan I know look at the neck roll
member like it now that's very it is
very Greg Olson like oh my gosh it's but
those neck rolls and like I remember the
arm pads because he didn't do him in the
photos but like the the way they would
smell around October just unbeliev I
think that's why I retired I retired
also because I didn't like to a days
here we are right in August
my daughter 15 she's into a daze I just
the smell of cut grass still makes me
like she does like three a days
what do you mean for soccer they do
three days they start they do one in the
morning I think they just did it for a
week then they do one in the afternoon
and then they have like a run-through at
night it's insane and you have to take
take her to a no no no she's she's out
in the wind I don't know what she's
doing
Jim Gaffigan here on the Rich Eisen show
so you were at didn't you perform for
owners at a what one was this again
which time it was it was when Indy
hosted the Super Bowl which was by the
way amazing
it was amazing it's like 60 degrees
outside the game was Patriots Giants
again it came down to the last second
again yeah Stadium was amazing the city
was lit the entire week yeah and you can
you could walk everywhere I know it was
amazing but ya know that was super weird
and I'm still kind of like I still have
images of Jerry Jones not laughing he's
a lot taller than I thought and he
doesn't think I'm funny at all I
remember the you know Mara the Giants
owner yeah who's passed away she I
remember thinking is that cuz she is
she's also like this iconic image I'm
like wait a minute
is that is that is that you know Rooney
Mara you mean Kate Morrow I know what
was yet it's their grandma yeah oh okay
Oh hairy butt lady look different the
the patrician of the the Giants yes
America's nickname is on the football
the Duke Wow
maybe that's why he wasn't laughing it
was I was very intimidated we weren't of
it but I remember the Chiefs
owners being very nice okay what were
your jokes
can you tell any of them I don't know
really can't you know I these these NFL
owners they haven't been to the grocery
store you know like these it's like you
can't do relatable man you know what
it's like when you're doing this cuz
they're like no we don't know do you I
mean it's like I don't have any material
of like when you know when you're 70 and
you're getting a lap dance I don't have
it I mean so you've updated your
material a little bit see that's how you
adapt you you you have to it all about
adapters right which the Colts will
adapt I the rear I totally agree with
you so you follow the Pacers and stuff
like no no I'm I'm lazy I uh like
there's too much effort involved like
I'm impressed but like that's why I'll
watch this show every now and then I'll
duck in Argo
all right this is what I should know
that's a real man but I don't have time
I don't have time well because you're
working all the time no doubt about what
is it like to be somebody from Indiana
living in New York City for 30 years
it's well first of all people still
think I'm a tourist every time I get in
a cab the cab driver is like where are
you from Texas you know and then I could
be going two blocks and they're like
would you like to go for the George
Washington Bridge I'm like no but can we
swing by LaGuardia so I can get some
groceries you know I look like a tourist
I mean it might be the boob inspector
t-shirt I'm wearing some I'm white bread
yeah alright so in it because to me
being in New York or living in Southern
California is an advantage to me like
for instance when you're getting off the
405 and people line up to get off the
one exit Lane right I'm I'm just
going right in front of everybody and
then you know that they're giving you
dirty looks but you don't care don't no
no I don't you know like I'll even
return visual visual fire if you will
just yeah you know I'll just even look
back at them as I'm just come on just
let me in I'd give them the
International look of like we're all
people here what's the matter with you
like I can do that because I have the
New York back well I would say being
Midwestern people I can be a nudge and
people are less likely to notice it what
do you mean so I can be kind of
persistent and because I'm Midwestern
filth they won't notice it initially
mm-hmm so I'll be like I I need that and
they're like well you know no where is
like if it was a New Yorker they'd be
like you're being obnoxious but I think
because I'm Midwest you're under the
radar I'm under the radar not that
you've got the Midwestern holiness well
mentally well not until they see
American dreamer I know it was right out
the window Jim I'd be very very honest
with you that's true so did you enjoy
this did you is amazing in boys playing
somebody who is a real huh I mean you
know anyone who has children sees their
kid kind of dress up and kind of pretend
to be someone else and that's what a
great acting role is you you get to kind
of embody someone who would make
different decisions and has different
priorities there's nothing and it's you
know I also selfishly love you know
doing these roles so because in the
entertainment industry you have to show
people exactly what you can do right and
so now because generally the
entertainment industry they're
risk-averse they're like what you know
if we're gonna cast this guy he's got to
be able to do it right and so this adds
to you know proofing what I can do
hopefully and then in terms of the
comedy world who would you pay to see
who would you say you know what I will
go to that person that individuals
well shall is the genius of the day
right mm-hmm but I think that I learn a
lot from Chris Rock I learn a lot from I
think Seinfeld's ironically underrated I
think that he has this pure comedy brain
that is
timeless it covers generations right
decades but have you gone in the car
with him did you do I did I went in the
car with what was that like it's it's
like it's like it was probably like you
talking to Bob Costas yeah I mean it's
like instead of talking about sports
we're talking but you know I've gotten
to know Jerry and it's just all comedy
and it's it's all kind of craft and it's
really fun and comedians are relatively
weird people like it's like people don't
understand that we're not doing it for
them we're doing it for us yeah I mean
it's like coming up with a new joke or
even a new line is better than any form
of heroin not that I've tried heroin any
form you just assume any form you're
assuming yeah it's odd that Costas
picked me up in a 50s Oldsmobile and we
went and got deli real it's no
sportscasters in cars getting deli I
don't know I mean just trying to fill in
the madly with an actual real comedian
but yeah you and like you know there's
some some sports casters that you guys
are cut from a different kind of cloth
right there is an obsession about sports
that is not universal right well I mean
I'm fortunate to in the same way that
I'm sure you feel fortunate to do what
you do for a living or should it's the
same thing right here you're like the
dead head of sports hmm right well I
Stromer I stroll around look at your
free apps teenis no no hold on a second
wait a minute
I have to draw the line on that one we
can edit that out escalated quickly I
would definitely say what what car did
what car did you drive around in with
them he put me in a camper you know you
got all these kids so it was like I
don't know camper VW they gotta watch
that one but I don't I'm not a car guy
are you a car guy not really no other
than my Honda Odyssey your Honda Odyssey
which you're not paid to plug
but I feel like that's it's a
generational break like the love of cars
obviously I have friends that are sure
similar in age to us even though I'm
much younger than you that I love cars
but compared to like my older brothers
and Seinfeld those people in Jay Leno I
mean they're obsessed Letterman they're
obsessed with cars they are obsessed
with cars you're that's kind of how they
feel about cars is how you feel about
your Honda Odyssey yeah what what what
Carter to have I think it's like a lime
green VW wagon there yeah it's a opens
up and you can camp inside of it yeah
and did you really get coffee yeah we
did we went to second Avenue deli
amazing pastrami very thin and I'm a
Katz's Deli guy but like it was good
that's amazing good American dreamer
debuts again had already had premiered
at the LA Film Festival last year in New
York on September 13th and then
nationally in theaters digital on demand
on September the 20th and you could
check out Jim Gaffigan quality time on
Amazon Prime it's the first original
comedy special there at Jim Gaffigan on
Twitter and Instagram be one of the
millions who follow this man love when
you come here Jim thanks for having me
anytime that's Jim Gaffigan right here
phone lines are lit eight four four two
oh four rich number two da will talk to
you and then talk to Pete Alonso of the
Mets and Jerry Ferrara and studio that's
how we're rollin here from here on out
in New York City for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app